merrigan bonsoir au soir donc vous êtes
grand reporter spécialiste de politique
étrangère auteurs de deux best-sellers
la guerre du golfe le dossier secret
avec pierre salinger est tempête du
désert et vous publiez un livre qui est
déjà un best-seller qui rentrait
directement je crois cinquième dans la
liste de l'express qui s'appelle la
guerre des bouches les secrets
inavouables
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez voir c'est énorme c'est un
livre qui est consacré à la famille bush
et on commence avec le grand père bush
prescott bush
prescott bush vous expliquer dans votre
bouquin comment il a fait fortune
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
grâce aux nazis à travers deux sociétés
l'une young banking corporation et la
cie les yoles american corporation et
cette deuxième société avait des mines
de charbon et de zinc en pologne en
allemagne et ses mines étaient exploités
en partie par des prisonniers des camps
absolument prescott bush a été en effet
donc un homme qui a fait toute sa
carrière en achetant des entreprises
durant après la deuxième guerre mondiale
les entreprises nazis et il y avait un
personnage qu'il est très proche de lui
et qui était petit säntis honnêteté et
fait carrément le banquier privé
d'hitler il avait d'ailleurs publié une
biographie qui s'appelait comment j'ai
financé hitler depuis 1923 1 donc voila
et la fortune des bouchers la dynastie
des bush s'est établi à partir en effet
de la trajectoire de ce personnage voilà
qui est devenu ensuite extrêmement
respectable a autorité et à l'intérieur
des établissements américains voilà donc
premières révélations vive d'eric
laurent le grand père de george w bush
faisait tout à fait officiellement y
siéger au comité de direction de la cie
les jeunes banking corporation dire
claude on les dit non non c'est juste un
morceau de pierre tout allait y avait
deux types d'activités à l'époque il y
avait parmi les sympathisants à une
sympathisant nazi y avait des kennedy
qui affiche effectivement ouais comme
joe kennedy opinion ouvertement pro pro
nazis mais qu'ils ne connaissaient pas
avec l'allemagne et il y avait près
scott bush qui lui commercer avec
l'allemagne et les activités étaient
suffisamment répréhensible pour qu'en
1942 le gouvernement de roosevelt
effectivement au nom de
l'inculpé pour
collaboration avec l'ennemi donc c'est
un revenant de l'ennemi actrice qu'on
appelait les miracles et les deux
entreprises d'ailleurs des bouchons ont
été saisis par les autorités fédérales
américaines
voilà premier scoop du bouquin et
règlements ça laisse rêveur non
non non on passe on passe aux pères
ainsi on a vu le grand père donc on
passe au père l'ex président george bush
donc lui il a été nommé en fait à la cia
un moment pour camoufler l'existence
d'une dune d'une agence qui s'appelle et
nsa national security agency et 7 7
agences contrairement au fbi ou un seuil
à nana été créée par aucune loi en fait
oui là nsm est une agence qui peut
mettre sur écoute le monde entier si
vous décrochez votre téléphone aux états
unis compris dans une cabine
téléphonique
vous êtes sur écoute donc il ya des
centres des côtes à travers le monde
entier il ya des relais tous les
satellites en effet donc qui servent à
transmettre des communications sont
placées sur écoute par la reine et c est
en effet george bush avait été chargé de
à la tête de la cia 2 camoufler les
activités qui étaient à l'époque comme
vous lisiez extrêmement
vraiment douteuses opaque de l'année
c'est qui n'a été créée en 1947 par un
acte spécial de l'administration truman
qui n'a jamais été rendue publique en
syrie et du budget ont servi à des
hommes voilà c'est ce qu'on voit en
général d'air dans les films de science
fiction c'est à dire une une agence qui
est répertorié nulle part qui n'existe
pas mais qui en fait existe bien puisque
après le fbi et la cia c'est la
troisième voie là alors le père bush
donc de georges bush lui il a un ami qui
s'appelle jim baffes et ce jim basse l'a
beaucoup soutenu c'est un vrai ami l'a
beaucoup soutenu pendant pendant ses
campagnes et il est associé se dit mme
baffe à un dénommé ravi de bin mahfouz
qui le patron de la bci alors c'est quoi
la bcc lice c'est une banque qui a été
créé par deux personnage c'est étonnant
deux pakistanais qui voulait créer un
grand établissement bancaire qui
pourrait faire contrepoids aux grandes
banques occidentales et qui pourrait
ainsi donc investir à travers les pays
du tiers monde c'était une entreprise
extraordinaire loi bien très simplement
il s'est avéré que la bcc y était la
plus grande organisation criminelle
qu'on n'ait jamais créé il y avait à
l'intérieur de la bci tous les comptes
en effet donc soit la mafia italienne
soit en effet par exemple les barons de
la drogue du cartel de medellin est
comme ça le roi de la drogue trafic
d'opium d'un triangle d'auray noriega
par exemple plus en effet je passe sur
abou nidal et quelques autres
terroristes qui avaient des comptes
réguliers voilà alors la baisse et s'est
hissé de cette banque dont vous parlez
où les saoudiens transférer leur argent
pour ben laden et pour al qaïda et je
rappelle que cette baie cci et est
possédé par khalid bin mahfouz qui est
un ami de jim basse qui lui même est un
grand ami de george bush exactement il
vous soyez en plus que monsieur khalid
bin mahfouz que vous évoquez le plus
gros bang et d'arabie saoudite est
également le beau frère d'oussama ben
laden oui c'est ça c'est très important
voilà exactement la soeur a épousé ben
laden en voie d'agréement alors ce bin
mahfouz il a aidé bouche aussi un trait
directement cette fois non pas par
l'intermédiaire de jean bart mais il a
été très directement la famille bush
dans une compagnie pétrolière qu'il
possède qui s'appelle arquennes il les a
aidés pour obtenir des facilités avec
certains émirats du golfe un oui parce
que effectivement jim basse donc était
un ami docile et george deubeuliou bush
l'actuel président il l'avait rencontrée
lorsqu'il a fait son service militaire
ensemble la garde nationale du texas et
donc à chaque fois au cours de la
carrière de bush l'actuel président
chaque fois qu en effet il connaîtra des
revers ils seront nombreux puisque en
effet on sera dans le pétrole et à
chaque fois avec un succès croissant à
chaque fois il sera renflouée par l'état
est très riche quand même d'un vert le
petit bouchon c'est pas un homme
d'affaires véritablement et donc à
chaque fois il sera renflouée par un
certain nombre d' effectivement d'amis
très cher dont bin mahfouz et dont ben
laden parce que ce jim basse aussi
parallèlement écart s'est activement
c'est un point tournant ce jim base de
vie à à partir de 1976 peu appel rachat
de ces compagnies l'homme d'affaires des
ben laden au texas et vous savez qu'elle
va être une des premières actions
avaient fait des ben laden ça va être le
rachat de l'aéroport de houston au texas
alors pendant toutes les années 80 donc
avant la première guerre du golfe il ya
de très bonnes relations entre les usa
et l'irak les américains financés et arm
saddam hussein pour l'aider à gagner sa
guerre contre l'iran un petit peu comme
ils ont soutenu d'ailleurs ben laden
pour lutter contre les soviétiques en
afghanistan c'est un petit peu le même
genre de méthode 1 et alors la cia aide
les irakiens à bien utiliser le gaz
moutarde ce gaz moutarde qu'il cherche
la mort en irak en fait c'est les
américains qui leur ont vendus mais non
seulement ils auront vendu mais la cia
leur a appris comment s'en servir contre
les iraniens oui c'est ça ll
effectivement les irakiens à calibrer
leurs attaques et leur taille contre les
troupes iraniennes au gaz moutarde en
effet bien sûr non seulement ça mais par
exemple les hélicoptères a fourni par
exemple qu'un à usage théoriquement
civils servent à saddam hussein a
bombardé les alarme chimique le fameux
village de la bahia qui kurdistan au
kurdistan géré que le kurdistan et c'est
très grave le kurdistan était bombardé
par des hélicoptères bell qui ont été
vendus par les américains à des fins
civiles et utilisés par saddam hussein à
des fins de génocide enfin tout est tout
simplement dur je bouge ira très loin
puisque malgré l'opposition en effet
donc d'une partie de son administration
il continuera à financer saddam hussein
il continuera à l'armée jusqu'au
premières semaines de la crise du golfe
oui parce qu'il militait bouche militer
pour qu'on donne des centaines de
millions de dollars 2 milliards d'euros
louis 5 milliards de dollars
tout ça par des circuits qui sont
absolument officieux et les circuits qui
sont même illégaux puisque ça ne
transitera par une banque italienne
installée effectivement dans l'état de
géorgie à atlanta sellaband zanella
vauxrot donc la banque du travail
italienne qui est une banque banque
d'état mais il ya beaucoup beaucoup
mieux d'en haut niveau du cynisme par
exemple à ce que bush père a la haute
main sur le dossier irakien au ses
administrations reagan et un nom donné
en 1983 on décide d'envoyer un émissaire
spécial auprès de saddam hussein oui
voilà et donc on en voit un homme qui va
rencontrer saddam hussein qui s'entendra
merveilleusement bien les bus qui
revient washington fait un rapport mais
alors dithyrambique sur saddam hussein
sur son régime en décidant qu'il faut le
soutenir l'armée et le finance et de
renforcer et vous savez qui c'est donald
rumsfeld exactement le ministre de la
défense américain celui qui est
aujourd'hui le faucon des faucons et qui
explique aujourd'hui l'irak une dent
geslin québec la fonctionnelle magne sur
la vieille europe exactement on continue
donc on passe à bush junior dont george
w bush alors lui il est très lié à un
fonds d'investissement qui s'appelle
carlyle 1 c'est une firme
d'investissement privée et où le père
travaille pour carla elle lui les traits
en osmose avec carlyle et et carlyle a
passé un contrat avec le pentagone de 12
milliards de dollars contre l'avis des
experts du pentagone
donc à la famille bush profite de sa
position et tour favoriser un fonds
d'investissement auxquels ils sont liés
d'une série carnaille est un organisme
d'une puissance considérable est un
fonds d'investissement pour le moment le
premier des états unis il a des actifs
de 16 milliards de donneurs se font au
travail dans l'industrie d'armement donc
il est considéré comme le 11e fabricant
d'armement des états unis par exemple à
l'heure actuelle les chars bradley les
chars lourds qui sont massés dans la
région du golfe et qui sont prêts à
foncer sur l'irak sont fabriqués par
d'une des entreprises contrôlées par
carlyle les missiles des missiles
pointés à bord des navires américains
dans la zone du golfe est prêt a
effectivement être tiré sur l'irak sont
également fabriquées par une des
filiales le quart lie aujourd'hui on est
dans une situation qui est au delà du
délit d'initié c'est à dire que le père
bush george bush père donc est un des
dirigeants de ce fonds d'investissement
carlyle qui négocie avec le pentagone
donc avec une administration dirigée par
son fils et qui donc bénéficient des
choix faits par son fils on peut
supposer qu à terme non seulement
évidemment monsieur bush père s'enrichit
mais à la limite lorsqu'il aura quitté
la présidence de george bush junior
bénéficiera évidemment des choix et des
investissements qu'il avait simulé une
situation scabreuse c'était assez
scabreux et règlement est ce que c'est
vrai que ben laden a été par bancs
interposés un actionnaire de carlyle ben
laden les peines à donne la famille ben
natalia l'énorme actionnaires de carlyle
il faut souligner qu' on ne peut pas et
c'est ça qui est fascinant est très
troublant on ne peut pas dissocier les
bouches des ben laden cuire pendant 25
ans alors j'ai bien admet qu'il existe
des relations d'affaires mais je veux
dire qu'on sauve quelqu'un a par exemple
de la faillite à plusieurs reprises
comme c'était le cas pour charge de
bennoo bougez vous évoquez tout à
l'heure à arquennes la compagnie
pétrolière 20 arquennes bon car kane a
comme dirigeante george deubeuliou bouge
une compagnie pétrolière qui ne réussit
pas effectivement obtenir des résultats
est abandonné elle va être mise en
faillite et sauvé de la faillite par ce
banquier saoudien pour évoquer avec
l'aide des ben laden et donc on va
trouver 25 millions de dollars qui vont
provenir notamment pour une part de la
bci et pour une autre partie de l'union
des banques suisses mais quand il ya le
11 septembre ben laden se retire du
fonds carlyle non ben laden se retire
pas de lait ben laden signés et les ben
laden officiellement ont désavoué aux
âmes à ben laden il faut le dire non il
faut être très clair bon il a donc lui
aussi il a perdu 1 a souhaité saoudien
depuis 94 mais il faudra attendre
octobre ou novembre pour que timidement
à grandes lignes on annonce que les les
ben laden se retire du fonds carlyle
mais tous les experts estiment que c'est
complètement faux et que donc on a
modifié effectivement la présentation
mais qu'ils sont toujours présents à
l'intérieur de ce fonds c'est là qu'ils
vont bénéficier évidemment de l'effort
d'armement et de la guerre qui
probablement aura lieu vous voulez
prouver quoi que les américains sont
responsables de tout ce qui se passe
même avant l'attentât du 11 septembre
même attitude
ah bon mais non mais cette année on en
est quand même est strictement rien vu
la façon dont vous raconter ainsi tous
ces faits non c'est on risque de
comprendre que tout retombe sur la tête
des américains et que c'est normal mais
ce qui arrive quoi en faire non les
choses entraînements dans les chaussures
tout à fait différent de l'attentât du
11 septembre est une clé pour comprendre
la politique américaine actuelle c'est
vrai qu'en effet il ya en effet à ce
moment là sentiment d'une formidable
fragilité et la nécessité de mener une
grande lutte contre le terrorisme on est
le 11 septembre
cinq jours plus tard déjà y lire une
inflexion majeure au sein de migration
américaine c'est à dire qu'il va y avoir
une réunion qui va être déterminante à
camp david kay la résidence d'été des
présidents et l'a donc bouche réuni ses
principaux collaborateurs et il ya
notamment un homme qui va s'avérer
déterminant pour l'évolution des choses
et notamment les grandes orientations et
choix de politique étrangère américain
cet homme s'appelle paul vol sous vide
c'est astana c'est un faucon c'est un
faucon mais c'est un homme aussi que
d'un intellectuel qui est en effet donc
l'ancien doyen l'université de princeton
et dont il ya une discussion et alors on
dit il faut évidemment frappé
l'afghanistan bien entendu tout moi est
d'accord mais là où il faut vite
intervient et d'écouté si on frappe en
effet les réseaux terroristes comme al
qaïda et ben laden sans frapper à des
pays capables de produire des armes de
destruction massive on est à côté
complètement de la plaque là on se
trompe il faut frapper les deux il faut
frapper les deux et 10 au premier rang
desquels il ya l'irak et la discussion
qui s'engage powell 10 miracle n'est pas
impliqué wolf vice dit quand on dit pas
encore l'irak ça veut dire jamais l'irak
il faut absolument en effet donc frappé
bagdad et à ce moment là bush qui est
tout de même dire qui naquit n'a pas une
grande expérience de politique étrangère
élevé et donc est assez fasciné par la
démonstration de vol faut vite sous main
parce que vos solitude y aussi vous êtes
un moment historique moment où
l'amérique non qui est délivrée en effet
de cette rivalité est-ouest a les mains
libres et va pouvoir en effet remodelé
probablement le reste du monde et
notamment par exemple le monde arabe qui
est une zone grande instabilité et bien
nous pouvons par exemple appliquer que
les schémas de la démocratie américaine
les imposé à l'irak et là nous aurons
une formidable vitrine démocratique qui
évidemment suscitera un grand effet de
contagion alors donc évidemment b bush
est subjuguée et donc quand il revient à
washington de la maison blanche deux
jours plus tard il dit notamment un de
ses proches collaborateurs condoleezza
rice la la la ouais et qui lui dit
écoutez on va commencer par
l'afghanistan mais l'irak et sur mon
agenda est en effet je suis persuadé que
saddam hussein est dans le coup leurs
pendants à ce que est ce que dit quand
même un dricot c'est que pendant que les
éric leurent fait cette enquête sur bush
les américains rappellent les liens que
la france avait avec l'irak on leur a
vendu des avions leur programme
nucléaire on a dû me mettre zéro à eauze
irak et puis les liens politiques pas
simplement chevènement mais même chirac
dans le mot ce que je trouve intéressant
c'est pas tellement d'attribuer justin
le risque c'est d'attribuer le cynisme
aux américains c'est la france c'est la
fin du cynisme politique ou plus
haletants c'est la démonstration du
cynisme politique mais on peut pas s'en
exonérer non plus quoi c'est ça que faut
pas tout mettre sur les américains
n'affichent plus me permettre un terme
formidable de notre président jacques
chirac qui quand il était premier
ministre je sais plus qui peut-être de
giscard sûrement à
10 de saddam hussein que c'était le 2
grohl du moyen-orient alors c'est quand
même extraordinaire bien merci merci
beaucoup votre bouquin donc s'appelle la
guerre des bouches les secret inavouable
d'un conflit c'est chez plon merci avec
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu